[Musique]
les 60 seront les prix spot de ma vie
c'est quand j'ai regardé les fermes
venues pour la première fois et qu'elle
est restée co 60 secondes secteur gers
est apposé un avion au nicaragua et en
même temps j'ai réussi à me défaire de
terroristes et a ramené les bijoux de la
castafiore c'était fou mais cette
soixante secondes de folie la première
fois avant de monter sur scène
je pense que c'est les plus forts la
plus folle parce que tu t'es dit et ce
qui était sûr de ce que tu vas faire là
c'est quand je l'aï rencontré c'était un
match timber l'euro 2000 je pense c'est
quand j'ai joué sous ecstasy quand j'ai
pu interviewer céline dion quand en
vidéo youtube
la fois où j'ai mangé un yaourt la toute
première alors les 60 plus belles
secondes de ma vie c'est l'expulsion de
ma fille il ya quatorze ans après 22
heures de merde mais 60 secondes de
bonheur quand j'ai eu mon chat
quant à une standing-ovation qui dure un
peu longtemps la fin d'un spectacle ça
fait toujours plaisir
c'est toujours assez fou c'est une
sensation que je ressens juste avant de
rentrer sur scène c'est quand je suis
sorti du ventre de ma mère c'est quand
j'ai essayé de rentrer dans le ventre de
ma mère je pense que c'est quand on est
à environ 6 grammes d'alcool
malheureusement il faut pas boire j'ai
une blague de mon spectacle sur les
crêpes au sucre j'adore ce monde mais
c'est là je peux pas vous la faire mais
ça doit vraiment sept jours sur sept
secondes à peu près ce super non c'est
quand on sortait avec un deuil tu que tu
as vu sur des réseaux sociaux et que tu
vois en vrai et ça peut être long je
pense que c'est celle ci parce que j'ai
pas la réponse
une franchise acheter quoi c'est le
droit dans une porte si un cheval en une
minute quand je joue généralement dans
le sud de la france
comme je me suis fait passer pour un fou
pour être réformé à l'armée
premier spectacle quand je dis voulu que
je raconte mon histoire est que personne
répond avec juste 3 qui disent non
ouvrir la porte du bureau de mon boss
aloqa pour l'annoncer je démissionnais
pour devenir humoriste scellé c'était
vraiment les plus longues dans cette
porte à dire ou au repas ou au pas et
j'ai voilà c'est pas celle qu'on est en
train de vie hors atos
alors c'est l'expulsion de ma fille
c'est quand on m'a tiré dessus et après
je me suis réveillée parce que j'étais
pas moins fait ça vite fait si celle ci
mais j'aime bien factice est quand j'ai
gagné une victoire de la musique
inoubliable 60 euros les plus gênantes
c'est qu'une fois on a fait un spectacle
et le mec a oublié d'ouvrir le rideau
est donc tout l'intro on était face
rideau je crois que ça va être à 60
minutes si ça marche pas ça va être 60
minutes très gênant globalement quand je
ne me souviens pas d'un prénom de
quelqu'un qui fait partie et quasiment
ma famille m'a des fois tu croises des
gens et ils disent
attends je te connais mes jeux ça va me
revenir à ces horribles et là c'est très
long déjà et ça fait que 20 et la
plupart du temps ça dure encore 40 il ya
14 ans au moment où
j'ai reçu un appel de cannes et qui m'a
dit est ce que tu veux participer à 60
je crois que c'est quand je suis rentré
chez moi de la première de mon spectacle
et que ma mère m a demandé si j'avais
gardé le ticket du pour que les gens il
rentrait tout écrit mon nom et tout ce
que j'ai dit ouais après ok enfin la
conversion mais quand même stewart bella
mis sur le frigo les cinq concerts je
pensais les dernières soixante secondes
de concert où on dit au revoir au public
et tout ça je pense et les moines puis
ce mouvement quand j'ai joué devant mes
parents qui étaient décédés moto c'est
quand tu me match et ouais et moi
c'était la taxe était tellement corpore
les plus chanceuses mais quand on m'a
appelé pour faire 60 je me suis dit mais
je suis bénie des dieux c'est la faux
j'ai trouvé 4 euros quatre pièces de 1
jeté là c'est incroyable
un euro à un autre euro et ce à quatre
fois donc ça faisait à peu près toutes
les 15 secondes j'avais trouvé une pièce
de 1
ça reste une simple je suis une fille je
sais tout faire en moins de 60 secondes
en skate je sais faire un
un kit flip toujours à mon âge c'est un
bon plat j'appelle sushi shop et elle
arrive direct c'est faire une vague de
avec princess incroyable je suis le seul
à faire et à - jean-claude van damme
qu'est ce qui est plus impressionnant de
wade ça c'est faire la goutte
je sais faire l'oiseau j'espère le
téléphone faire des bruits qu'on
développe et par les japonais jongler
mes couilles mais bon ça n'a aucun
intérêt aucun rapport avec ce qu'on fait
ce soir je peut imiter l'expresso
commandé dans un bar ça va pas durer 60
mais j'ai plus de souffle pour la mousse
[Musique]